We've looked closely at circles, so now let's examine ellipses. Ellipses are
very much like circles. There's just one exception. The distance we go in the x
direction will be different from the distance we go in the y direction. So,
sometimes we might move further from the center in the x direction than we
would vertically in the y direction. And other times we might go further in the
y direction from the center, than we would in the x direction from the center.
We'll see a lot of similarities between circles and ellipses, so let's try
looking at a circle first. There's this amazing online graphing calculator
called Desmos. If you've never heard of it, I highly recommend that you check
it out. It allows us to easily enter in equations. And we can instantly see
what the graph looks like. For now we're going to look at the equation of a
circle, but if you ever want to play around with this on your own, go to
www.decimals.com. You can create your own account and then start to draw and
save your own graphs. For circles we know they have equal amounts of x squared
and y squared. And if we take the square root of this number, we'll get six.
That's the radius of our circle. The distance to any point from the center to
another point on the circle. But what if we wanted to graph this equation?
Notice that we have different amounts of x squared and y squared now. Now, I'm
going to go ahead and let you know that this will be the graph of an ellipse.
So, let's see how we can graph it ourselves. First we'll take the equation and
we'll divide through by the number 36. When we divide each term by 36, we'll
get one fourth x squared here. one ninth y squared here and 1 on the other side
of the equal sign. So, we're going to ignore our first equation of the circle
for now. We've taken this equation and rearranged it into this. Now, can you
tell me what are the two x-intercepts?